après plusieurs minutes de
tergiversations l'endroit est enfin
trouvée voici la nouvelle place charlie
à vierzon une inauguration symbolique
qui ne rassemble pas grand monde
et pourtant il semble plus que jamais
nécessaire de rappeler le sens de
l'esprit charlie il n'y a pas de racisme
c'est pas l'intolérence n'est pas
d'islamophobie voilà il ya simplement
parce que courrait 10 ans michel et il
pourrait le décider c'est à dire voilà
la lutte quotidienne contre la connerie
ambiante
voilà une initiative citoyenne et
apolitique l'annoncé a été faite sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans la presse en
janvier dernier un millier de personnes
avaient manifesté à vierzon aujourd'hui
ils ne sont plus qu'une poignée
d'irréductibles animé par la défense de
toutes les libertés
pour moi c'était très important à titre
personnel parce que depuis trente ans je
me suis rendu compte en manger 53 ans
que les libertés quelle qu'elle soit
s'effilochait ébats de d'année en année
et que là on en était arrivé à ne plus
pouvoir s'exprimer librement sur divers
sujets le journaliste redoutent que l'on
se trompe de débat que les antilles
charlie gagne du terrain que l'ignorance
et la confusion l'emportent sur les
élans spontanés du 7 janvier
quand les gens sont sortis dans la rue
le 7 au soir quand il s'est passé tous
agir ils sont pas posé de questions ils
n'y sont pas allées en se posant la
question est-ce que je suis raciste
islamophobe est ce que je suis en ti
cats aux antilles tout ils y sont allés
parce qu'il s'est passé un truc horrible
c'est pas l'islamophobie dont il est
question c'est du racisme
et pendant qu'on parle l'islamophobie on
parle pas du racisme quotidien de tout
ce qui se passe voilà on met un voile là
dessus si je peux dire ça et un moment
donné c'est le débat est biaisé donc il
faut revenir aux sources du débat la
place charlie restera-t-elle devant le
skate park
pas si sûr in fine et c'est le maire de
vierzon qui aura le dernier mot et le
collectif souhaite que le lieu retenu
soit un lieu de rencontre et de débat
ouvert au public est fidèle à l'esprit
charlie